you guys don't know how you doing man
I'm tutoring nice to meet you one that's
not you one all right Hey
que pasa
[Music]
tequila business started 22 years ago 22
years ago okay I started my mother's
kitchen then this guy helped me a few
years after and we built it from the
scratch you the man behind it Wow I know
the man
[Music]
this collection is called Mexico through
the time to show the cultural richness
of Mexico it was a 35 people team
working two years to make this happen
okay and everything from the what's
inside to the outside everything ok so
what we did first is choose 15 different
eras of Mexico for example this one is
focal boo is the name that the sacred
book that the Mayans had that book it's
written in keachi
to change the language of the Mayans so
on the case you can read each head this
is the letters of the chain this
represent a feather snake who was in the
first day running around the earth a
table it's a solid piece of amber 22
million years old 22 million this piece
[Music]
[Music]
Zomba it's amber
let me actually about nothing what about
this I like this box tell me about that
this bottle is called the 40 Weezer's
and then our this one is la noche triste
thus at night
this is called the margin ballgame this
one kind of animation on the bar it's
called the celebration and it's a story
of all the famous Mexican people
attending a party the smell of this
boxes remember I don't know if you can
smell this it's Elina laughs to call
Elina la you had to use the specific
word you have to use in specific colors
comes from minerals on the ground from
the ground
give me some prices man what is some
list of cars so we lounge this
collection seven years ago we saw three
bottles individually at $30,000 each a
few years ago we decided not to sell
individual anymore so the whole
collection is four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars but all goes to a
nonprofit organization to keep helping
people who doesn't have opportunities is
it good I can taste it no I was way
knows in my environment for you from
from a favorite bottle it's a blend of
two different tasks one cask been rest
for 11 years and the other one being
rest for 15 years in a sherry cask but
that sherry cask was seal made 27 1997
when Europe approved the Mexican
appellation of origin tequila how you
unlock and how you until we found that
cask you found it what was it like a
myth did you just hear about it you know
exactly where was it
[Music]
I knew about that Cass and I talked with
the owner and said I had to buy that
cast car then we share half of half
that's why we blend it so this is a
blend of tequila's the plan of the best
of the best best or this can get sued
isn't get sued she let me go smell a bit
[Applause]
yes is strong
but because of tonight we make something
special for you because of tonight
because of note you are not a manager
just so much fun
yes so it's the no J this hard that's
her phone that's hard
yes people you don't have one
you don't have one you don't have one
you do